big story this week there's been a lot
of friction between the trump
administration
and their top health official dr anthony
fauci
the president's often contradicting
fauci's medical opinion about covet-19
the white house even sent out a document
detailing
all the times dr fauci has been wrong
well the president insists he has a good
relationship with the doctor
but i wanted to dig a little deeper so
here to talk about the president's
relationship with dr fauci is senior
white house advisor ken wheatley
hello ken good to see you hello conan i
i'm happy to answer any and all
questions with 100
honesty and transparency thank great
great
well no no no no ken ken ken come back i
didn't ask anything yet
it seems like the white house is making
a pretty aggressive effort to hurt dr
fauci's reputation
no nothing could be further from the
truth the the president loves dr
fauci and his constant stream of
buzzkill news
fauci's a lot of fun okay look
i hear you i know that fauci delivers a
lot of difficult news but don't you
think america needs to hear it from
someone
like dr fauci a medical professional who
has a lot of credibility
does he though i mean he's been wrong on
quite a few things conan
early on maybe a few missteps but back
then
nobody knew much about how kovid spreads
i'm not even talking about his
covet statements conan dr fauci's been
wrong a lot and
it's all in here and uh you know let me
just give me an example give me an
example of when he's been wrong
well i i looked up his office oscar pool
from last year
and he had ford v ferrari winning it all
is that someone you can trust a lot of
people picked ford v ferrari they did
okay well dr fauci said and i quote
that tv show the office didn't really
hit its
stride until steve carell left
okay yeah all right that's clearly not
accurate or a good take on something but
i don't think it's a huge deal
all right there's more on his driver's
license it says he's 5 10. okay that's a
demonstrable lie
and guess what fauci puts on his hot
dogs
i don't know ketchup cream cheese and
his favorite james bond is timothy
dalton
oh my oh god that's bad
yeah you know when i saw the sixth sense
with dr fauci
he kept leaning over and whispering
there's no way
bruce willis is actually dead and i once
saw him bite into a zucchini
then spit it out and say gross i thought
it was a cucumber
honest mistake right but what kind of a
lunatic takes a bite out of a whole
cucumber
all right okay but none of what you're
saying has anything to do with his
medical opinion
all right well okay how can you trust
his medical opinion when he tells
everyone to wear a protective mask and
yet here's a photo of
fauci without a mask
that photo is from the 1990s he was
receiving the presidential medal of
freedom
for his groundbreaking aids research
it's obvious you guys are just trying to
tarnish his reputation because he's
polling better than trump
well that's just your opinion no no
that's actually a fact
well as the president says facts are
just opinions that run like a girl
but as i said we all adore dr fauci
and uh hang on the sun's getting in my
eyes here
there it's much better we all adore him
and we are behind him 100 percent
okay uh ken wheatley everybody oh fouchy
stayed with quitty after the free trial